Hallo zusammen, ich bin Fabio von Three Wings und wir schauen heute zusammen das Thema Meteo an.
Es geht hier vor allem um eine Prüfungsvorbereitung oder um Meteo-Basics generell.
Es gibt für mich in der Meteorologie zwei Arten, wie man lernen kann.
Das eine ist Minimumaufwand, irgendwie durch die Theorieprüfung durchzukommen.
Und dann gibt es natürlich sehr viel mehr Wetterwissen, das man vermitteln kann und lernen kann.
Und da gibt es eigentlich fast keine Grenzen und da könnte man fünf Tage darüber reden, über Meteorologie.
Dieser Kurs ist jetzt aber so, dass er wirklich auf Basics ausgelegt ist.
Dieser Kurs eignet sich sicher auch für schon präventierte Piloten,
um vielleicht das Wetterwissen wieder ein bisschen auffrischen, um neue Sachen dazulernen.
Es hat sicher auch viele spannende Gebiete dabei für präventierte Piloten.
Aber dieser Kurs ist natürlich vor allem auch auf Flugschulen ausgelegt,
so dass wir euch hoffentlich das Wetterwissen gut vermitteln können,
was im Theoriebuch vielleicht eher trocken ist und viele Sachen ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen sind.
Und ja, so steigen wir doch jetzt mal ein in das spannende Gebiet des Wetterwissens.
Ein Thema, das mir auch immer ganz am Herzen liegt, vor allem wenn es um Meteorologie geht,
ist, dass es ein bisschen zwei Bereiche gibt.
Das eine ist das theoretische Wetterwissen, wo man viel lernen kann, viel Theorie verstehen kann.
Aber gerade in der Meteorologie spielt sich ja das Wetter von aussen ab.
Das hat sehr viel mit der Erfahrung zu tun, in der Flugpraxis oder in der Meteorpraxis.
Sehr viel damit zu tun, dass man das Wetter immer wieder beobachtet, analysiert
und die Theorie mit der Praxis auch immer wieder abgleicht.
Und das ist auch ganz wichtig.
In diesem Bereich geht es aber hauptsächlich um Theorie und um ein gewisses Grundverständnis für das Wetter.
Fangen wir vielleicht gleich beim Grössten an. Wo spielt sich das Wetter ab?
Das ist in unserer Atmosphäre.
Die Atmosphäre rund um die Welt ist aufteilt in verschiedene Gebiete.
In Stratosphären, Mesosphären, Troposphären.
Für uns aber am relevantesten ist eine Troposphäre,
die oben dran begrenzt ist mit der sogenannten Tropospause.
Und in dieser Schicht unten befinden sich eigentlich die meisten Luftfeuchtigkeiten,
der meiste Wasserdampf und somit das, was für uns wetterbestimmend ist.
Diese Troposphäre ist extrem dünn.
Wenn man aus dem Weltraum schaut, aus einer Raumstation heraus,
dann ist das nur eine ganz dünne Schicht, die man hier erkennt.
Ungefähr vom Massstab ist sie so wie eine Zwiebelschelfe.
Das ist wirklich ein ganz, ganz dünner Bereich, wo sich das Wetter geschehen abspielt
und wo wir uns natürlich auch bewegen.
Und wir als Gletschernflüger bewegen sich ja sogar nur in der untersten Schicht dieser Troposphäre.
Und ...
Hier wichtig in der Theorie, das müsst ihr auch für die Theorieprüfung wissen,
die Zusammensetzung der Gase in dieser Troposphäre.
Zwar sind das die 21% Sauerstoffe, die für uns wichtig sind zum Atmen natürlich,
die 78% Stickstoffe und dann gibt es noch 1% Edelgas,
welches zum Beispiel auch dazu gehört.
Das ist aber für uns, für die Meteorologie, nicht von grosser Relevanz,
die restlichen Edelgase, die da drin sind.
Die Troposphäre ist nicht rund um den Globus gleich dick.
Sie ist an den Polen oben etwas dünner als am Äquator.
Das hat mit der Erdrotation zu tun.
Am Äquator ist sie ungefähr 18 km und am Pol oben ungefähr 8 km.
Bei uns in Europa, von der Breite gerade her, wo wir ja viel am Fliegen sind,
sind wir ungefähr 11-13 km dick von dieser Troposphäre.
Das müsst ihr euch auch vorstellen, diese 13'000 m.
Dann reden wir von einer Standardatmosphäre.
Das ist immer wieder wichtig im Flugwetter oder vor allem in der Theorieprüfung.
Fragen sie euch immer wieder aus über die Standardatmosphäre.
Das ist diese Atmosphäre, wenn sich das Wetter komplett ausgleichen würde,
wenn wir keine Hochdruckgebiete hätten, Tiefdruckgebiete
und verschiedene Faktoren, die unser Wetter beeinflussen,
die wir jetzt anschauen werden.
Wenn sich da alles ausgleichen würde, dann kommt ihr auf eine sogenannte Standardatmosphäre.
Das ist so wie der Nullpunkt, wo sich alles ausgleichen hat.
Da gibt es ein paar Zahlen und Facts, die ihr an der Theorieprüfung abrufen müsst.
Das Wichtige ist der Temperaturgradient in der Höhe,
wie sich die Troposphäre abkühlt.
Und zwar reden wir hier von 6,5 Grad pro 1000 Höhenmeter
oder pro 100 Meter, dementsprechend 0,65 Grad pro 100 Meter.
Dann reden wir an der Erdoberfläche der Standardatmosphäre von 15 Grad
und an der Troposphäre oben von minus 56 Grad.
Vor allem die unteren zwei Zahlen sind wichtig,
die ihr lernt für die Theorieprüfung.
Der Temperaturgradient ist natürlich je nach Wetterlage und Situation,
wie wir später lernen können, natürlich variieren.
Aber in der Standardatmosphäre reden wir, wie gesagt, von 6,5 Grad pro 100 Meter.
Dann haben wir die Temperaturen.
In der Standardatmosphäre reden wir auch von einem Standardluftdruck.
Den Luftdruck können wir nachher noch gar nicht darauf sprechen.
Aber sicher die Zahl, die wir auch immer wieder hören werden,
sind die 1013,25 Hektopascal.
1013,25 Hektopascal ist der Luftdruck,
wenn sich, wie gesagt, die ganze Troposphäre ausgleicht.
Dann wäre auf Meereshöhe gerechnet der Luftdruck immer gleich.
Und dann wäre auf diesen 1013,25 Hektopascal.
Und die Troposphärenhöhe, wo die Tropospause dann anfängt,
ist bei 11 Kilometern in der Standardatmosphäre.
Dann beim Luftdruck auch wichtig ist,
wie sinkt er in der Höhe.
Das ist nicht linear.
Da kann man sagen,
dass sich alle 5500 Meter in der Höhe der Luftdruck halbiert.
Also dementsprechend auf 5500 Meter hätten wir noch 506,6 Hektopascal.
Das ist auch ein Wert in 5500 Meter,
der sehr wichtig ist für die Theorieprüfung, um das zu lernen.
Also der Druck nimmt natürlich in der Höhe ab.
Man kann sich den Luftdruck auch vorstellen.
Das ist wie eine Luftsäule,
die auch bei uns ist bis zur Tropospause hoch.
Und das ist gleich wie im Wasser zum Beispiel.
Die, die tauchen,
je tiefer man in dem Wasser geht,
desto höher ist der Druck durch die Gravitation der Erde.
Und dementsprechend ist natürlich der Luftdruck am höchsten,
am untersten Punkt auf Meereshöhe
und nimmt in der Höhe ab.
Das hat mit der Gravitation zu tun
und mit der Luftsäule,
die auf uns wirkt
und dementsprechend einen Luftdruck generiert.
Hier die Zahlen nochmal kurz zusammengefasst.
1013,25, 15 Grad
und die 0,65 auf 100 Meter.
Das sind die Zahlen,
die für uns für relevant sind
für die Standardatmosphäre.
Genau.
Und wenn wir uns überlegen,
die Standardatmosphäre
ist natürlich nicht immer gleich,
wie wir es ja jeden Tag erleben mit dem Wetter.
Da kommt der Motor dazu,
die Sonne,
die auf die Erde scheint und wirkt.
Und verschiedene Land- und Meerwasser
werden verschieden erwärmt.
Verschiedene Jahreszeiten auch.
Mit den verschiedenen Einstrahlwinkeln
der Sonne je nach Jahreszeit.
Ihr kennt es,
die Sonne ist ja nicht immer gleich hoch.
Und dementsprechend kommt das ganze
Gefüge, also die Standardatmosphäre
aus dem Gleichgewicht
und es gibt Schwankungen im Luftdruck
und auch mit den ganzen Wettersystemen.
Also die Sonne ist ein ganz wichtiger Motor,
der das aus dem Gleichgewicht bringt
und das Wetter verschieden beeinflusst.
Und das schauen wir uns jetzt zusammen an,
was das für einen Einfluss gibt.
Die Sonne,
die auf die Erde scheint,
erwärmt primär den Boden.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Eine Sonne erwärmt nie eine Luftmasse,
die sie durchscheint.
Eine Luft reflektiert ja keine Sonne
oder kann sich auch nicht erwärmen durch das.
Es erwärmt eigentlich nur
die bodennahe Luftschicht.
Das ist die Luftschicht,
die wirklich auf dem Boden aufliegt.
Mit der Abstrahlungswärme,
die dann entsteht
und die bodennahe Luftschicht erwärmt sich dann.
Und durch die Erwärmung
dieser bodennahen Luftschicht
gibt es Regionen auf der Welt,
verteilt auf dem Globus,
die sich verschieden erwärmen.
Regionen am Äquator erwärmen sich
natürlich mehr als in einer Region
irgendwo in der Polargegend,
wo die Sonnenstrahlen
nur sehr flach aufkommen.
Respektive eine Eisfläche
erwärmt sich auch weniger,
z.B. eine Wüste
oder ein Waldgebiet etc.
Und dadurch
erwärmen sich verschiedene Gebiete
auf dem Globus verschieden
und so entstehen verschiedene
Luftmassen.
Wenn wir von Luftmassen
sprechen, das ist auch ein Wort,
das in der Meteorologie immer wieder vorkommt.
Eine Luftmasse ist
eigentlich ein Luftvolumen,
das gleiche Eigenschaften hat.
Also wir haben z.B. eine erwärmere
Luftmasse und eine kältere.
Und das sind immer Gebiete,
die über mehrere hundert Kilometer
gleiche Eigenschaften haben,
also einen gleichen Luftdruck haben
oder eine gleiche Temperatur haben
oder eine ähnliche Temperatur haben,
eine wärmere Temperatur oder eine kältere Temperatur.
Grundsätzlich ist es so,
über ein Gebiet, das länger kälter ist
als die Umgebung,
wird ein höherer
Luftdruck entstehen.
Und über ein Gebiet, das länger warm ist
als die Umgebung,
entsteht ein tieferer Druck.
Dementsprechend gibt es in den tropischen
Gebieten z.B. die tropischen
Tiefdruckgebiete und in den
polaren Gebieten gibt es die polaren
Hochdruckgebiete.
So entstehen verschiedene Luftdrücke.
Und dann entstehen eben die Tiefdruckgebiete
und die Hochdruckgebiete,
worauf wir jetzt in den nächsten
Folien eingehen werden,
was das für einen Einfluss
auf unser Wetter hat.
Man kann sich vorstellen, dass es so wie
Gürtel gibt rund um die Welt.
Rund um den Globus gibt es die sogenannten
Hochdruckzellen.
Das sind die Tiefdruck- und Hochdruckringe.
Da gibt es noch mehr wie auf dieser Grafik.
Grundsätzlich ist es aber so, dass
in den tropischen Gebieten ein Quartal
Tiefdruck gibt und in den polaren Gebieten
Hochdruckgürtel gibt.
Und so gibt es auch tropische
Luftmassen und polare
Luftmassen. Und auch da werden wir
jetzt in den nächsten paar Minuten
lernen, was das für einen Einfluss
auf unser Wetter hat.
Das haben wir gerade gehabt.
Es gibt verschiedene Erwärmungen
von den verschiedenen Gebieten.
Dementsprechend gibt es ein Hochdruckgebiet
und ein Tiefdruckgebiet.
Und da seht ihr jetzt in der Mitte
die Zahlen, die wir gerade vorhin hatten
von dieser Standardatmosphäre,
die 1013,25.
Und sobald der Luftdruck wieder sinkt
und tiefer ist,
reden wir von einem Tiefdruckgebiet.
Bei uns in Europa
ist es ein sehr ausgeprägtes
Tiefdruckgebiet von
955 Hektar Pascal.
Und ein sehr ausgeprägtes
Tiefdruckgebiet, reden wir mal von
1035 Hektar Pascal.
Jetzt in der Zeit der globalen Erwärmung
werden leider die Werte auch immer
etwas extremer. Es gibt sogar
Hochdruckgebiete, die zum Beispiel
bis 1048 Hektar
Pascal erreichen. Also das sind dann
sehr starke Druckunterschiede.
Und dementsprechend werden auch
die meteorologischen Phänomene immer stärker.
Und das ist das, was wir
leider immer wieder erleben.
Mit diesen Unwetter zum Beispiel
hat es genau mit diesen
Druckschwankungen zu tun, die immer stärker werden.
Dann wichtig
für uns zum Wissen ist,
da kommen wir auch später noch
zum Zusammenhang dazu,
in den Hochdruckgebieten sinken
die Luftmassen und im Tiefdruckgebiet
steigen die Luftmassen. Das ist dann später
ganz wichtig für
das Flugwetter auch, wo wir
nachher dazu kommen.
Und grundsätzlich, wie jedes Gas
oder jede Flüssigkeit
hat die Luftmassen
das Bedürfnis, um einen Druck
auszugleichen. Das heisst,
eine Luftmasse will immer vom
Hochdruck ins Tiefdruck fliessen,
weil sie den Druck ausgleichen will.
Und dementsprechend ist vor allem
bei uns am Boden oder in den
tieferen Luftschichten diese
Luftströmung wichtig, dass
die Luft vom Hoch ins Tief
fliesst und dementsprechend
entstehen auch die Wind,
die Windsysteme, die wir
am Boden spüren, wenn der Wind bläst.
Und
so gibt es eine Ausgleichsströmung,
die für uns dann wichtig ist,
um diese Windrichtungen
zu erkennen und herauszulesen.
Dann kommen wir zu
den Isoparenkarten, ein Wort, das
ihr sicher auch schon gehört habt oder im Theoriebuch
schon gelesen habt. Es gibt
Wetterkarten, die genau diese
Wetterphänomene, die wir gerade besprochen haben,
beschreiben. Diese Wetterkarten
entstehen einerseits
aus aktuellen Messwerten,
wo man mit Barometern den
Luftdruck misst und
natürlich auch diese Computermodelle,
die dann aufgrund dieser Messungen
das Wetter probieren zu
prognostizieren und vorauszurechnen.
Und dann entstehen
diese lustigen Wetterkarten,
die wir jetzt auch noch genauer
eingehen, wie man diese herausliest.
Isoparenkarten,
Isopare
sind die Linien, die
man hier sieht. Isopare
beschreiben Gebiete,
die den gleichen Luftdruck haben.
Oder wo der gleiche
Luftdruck vorausgesagt wird.
Also wir haben hier einen Isobar
zum Beispiel von 1025 Hektopascal,
das sieht man jetzt auch nicht gut, in der nächsten
Karte kann man es einfach besser sehen.
Und überall wo diese Linie durchgeht,
wird auf Meereshöhe, das ist ganz wichtig,
der Druck wird heruntergerechnet auf
Meereshöhe, der gleiche Luftdruck
herrscht. Von dem her kommt der Name
Isoparenkarten.
Iso gleichbleibend, bar ist Druck.
Also überall wo der gleiche Druck
herrscht, wird eine solche Linie
eingezeichnet. Und auf so einer
Isoparenkarte sind oft auch Fronten
eingezeichnet natürlich, da kommen wir dann auch später
in diesem Kurs noch etwas genauer dazu,
was mit diesen Fronten
zu sehen ist.
Da sieht man noch etwas grössere Isoparenkarten,
da sieht man wieder die Hochdruckgebiete,
Tiefdruckgebiete, die wir jetzt gerade besprochen haben,
wo dann verschieden Luftdruck entstanden
ist, durch die Sonne und
durch auch die Jahreszeiten zum Beispiel.
Und so
sieht eine etwas grösser dargestellte
Isoparenkarte aus. Die sehen immer ein bisschen
anders aus, je nach Zeitung
oder je nach Meteoservice.
Sie sehen ein bisschen anders aus, aber im Grundsatz
haben eigentlich alle die gleichen Elemente
drin. Da sind dann nochmals die Hoch- und
Tiefdruckgebiete, Isoparen, und
die farbigen Linien, die
Fronten. Genau.
So sieht das dann auch aus. Jetzt nochmals
von einfach gezeigt auf unserem
Globus die verschiedenen Druckgebiete,
die entstehen über verschiedene Land- und
Meeresmassen.
Die haben verschiedene Druck, das sind wieder
Tiefdruck, und
durch die Kryoliskraft,
das ist ein
physikalisches Phänomen durch
die Erderotation,
werden
verschiedene Luftmassen,
die in Bewegung kommen,
abgelenkt.
Und dadurch entstehen
zyklische Bewegungen, also
rotierende Bewegungen.
Bildlich gesprochen
ist ein Abfluss zum Beispiel,
durch verschiedene Kräfte
oder die Form des Abflusses entsteht
ein Strudel. Wenn
das Wasser in Abfluss
abfließt, beginnt es zu rotieren.
Und so entsteht eine Drehbewegung.
In der Luftmasse ist
vor allem die Kryoliskraft ausschlaggebend,
dass die
Luftmassen anfangen
zu rotieren. Und dementsprechend
auf der Nordseite
unseres Globus,
also alles nördlich vom
Äquator, ist es so,
dass in einem Hochdruckgebiet
die Luftmassen im
Uhrzeigersinn drehen und
in einem Tiefdruckgebiet im
Gegenuhrzeigersinn.
Ich habe mir hier einen Eselsbruch gebaut,
dass für mich ein Hochdruckgebiet etwas Positives ist,
weil hier die Sonne scheint und schönes
Wetter ist und Flugwetter ist.
Dementsprechend ist es etwas Positives.
Und für mich ist der Uhrzeigersinn,
die Zeit läuft, im positiven Sinn.
Vorwärts habe ich mir einen Eselsbruch gebaut,
im Hochdruckgebiet im
Uhrzeigersinn, im Tiefdruckgebiet im
Gegenuhrzeigersinn, die Rotation.
Auf der südlichen
Hemisphäre, also jetzt zum Beispiel
in Australien, funktioniert das
Ganze genau gegengesetzt.
Einfach für diejenigen, die in die Ferien
fliegen und in Südamerika fliegen,
oder in Australien fliegen gehen,
dort ist es genau gegengesetzt.
Ganz eindrücklich sieht man
das natürlich im Fall von einem
Hurricane. Da sieht man richtig,
wie die Luftmasse rotiert. Ein
Hurricane ist nichts anderes
als ein extremes Tiefdruckgebiet
und dementsprechend sieht man,
das ist jetzt ein Hurricane,
das ist auf der nördlichen
Halbkugel, sieht man, wie das im
Gegenuhrzeigersinn rotiert
und in das Tiefdruckgebiet
hineingesagen wird, diese Luftmasse.
Das sieht man
sehr schön auf diesem
Wolkenbild eines Hurricanes.
Und dementsprechend, wir haben ja vorhin
in der Folie gesehen, dass die Luftmasse
den Druck ausgleichen möchte, sie fliesst
vom Hochdruck ins Tiefdruckgebiet,
die fliesst aber nicht in einer direkten
Linie vom
Hoch ins Tief, sondern sie wird
eben, wie die Corioliskraft beschrieben,
in eine rotierende Bewegung
in die Gebiete wechseln.
Dementsprechend
geht die Luftmasse in so eine
spiralförmige Bewegung
genau in das Tiefdruckgebiet hinein.
Um die Windrichtung
dann herauszulesen, das werden wir
nachher auf der Karte anschauen,
werden wir dann noch in ein paar Folien
später nochmal sehen, wie man die
Windrichtung in der isobaren Karte herausliest.
Man kann auch
eine Windstärke herauslesen
aus dieser isobaren Karte.
Vielleicht noch bildlich gesprochen,
als Vergleich zur isobaren Karte
kann man auch immer ein bisschen wie eine
Topografiekarte lesen.
Das sind verschiedene Höhenlinien,
verschiedene Drucklinien und dementsprechend
kann z.B. ein Hochdruckgebiet
verschieden hoch sein.
Also ein Hochdruckeinfluss dementsprechend
ist verschieden stark.
Wir haben z.B.
einen 50er von einem Hochdruckgebiet,
der ist extrem stark, der hat sehr viele
isobare Linien, sehr viele Topografielinien
im Sinne der Landschaft.
Oder es kann auch nur ein Hügel sein,
aber der Hoch
beschreibt eigentlich nur den
höchsten Druck, also eigentlich
die höchste Erhebung der Landschaft
oder von diesem Hügel.
Dementsprechend kann der höher sein
oder weniger hoch. Dementsprechend
sind auch die Wettereinflüsse,
die wir jetzt gerne noch besprechen,
stärker oder weniger stark.
Was wir machen, schauen wir uns rasch an,
wie man aus so einer isobaren Karte
eine Windrichtung herauslässt.
Wir haben grundsätzlich,
das ist eine Infografik aus einer
Theorieprüfung, wie sie kommt,
haben wir verschiedene Druckgebiete,
wie wir sie gesehen haben.
Jetzt machen sie eure Prüfung natürlich
nicht so einfach, wo sie gleich ein H und ein T
reinsetzen und ihr gleich wisst, wo das
Hoch- und Tiefdruckgebiet ist. Dementsprechend
wollen sie, dass ihr den Druck
von diesen Isobaren herausleset und
ihr seht z.B. hier bei Skandinavien oben,
man kann es relativ schlecht lesen,
80 Hektopascal z.B.
Das weiss man, das ist unter
diesen 1013,25.
Das muss also ein Tiefdruck sein.
Dementsprechend könnt ihr euch dort vorstellen,
ihr könnt auch den T ruhig hineinschreiben,
wenn ihr wollt.
Dementsprechend wissen wir, dass die
Luftmasse in diesem Tiefdruckgebiet
im Gegenuhrzeiger rotiert.
Und nachher kann man sich
auf diesen Isobaren Linien,
die man hier sieht, wenn man will,
Pfeile hineinzeichnen oder man kann es sich
auch noch vorstellen,
kann man sich den Isobaren Linien
an die Pfeile vorstellen,
jetzt habe ich es hier in Weiss gezeigt
und dementsprechend wird die Windrichtung herausgelesen.
Also hier z.B.
in England haben wir
eine Westwindströmung.
Und im Hochdruckgebiet,
hier haben wir die 1030 Hektopascal,
dort haben wir die höchste Erhebung,
dort ist der Hochdruck, dort rotiert es
im Uhrzeigersinn, dementsprechend
geht der Wind den Isobaren an.
Und ihr könnt wirklich
sehen, für die Theorie ist es so,
dass der Wind immer parallel
zu den Isobaren herausgelesen wird.
Also ihr nehmt wirklich die Linie
und das ist die Windrichtung,
weil der Druck in einer zirkulierenden Bewegung
ausgeglichen wird.
Genau, das ist für die Windrichtung.
Ihr könnt euch auch vorstellen,
dass der Hoch- und Tiefdruckgebiet
eigentlich wie ein Zahnradsystem funktioniert.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
das sind wie zwei Zahnrädchen,
die ineinander hineingreifen
und man kann sich vielleicht besser vorstellen.
Wie man den Wind herauslässt,
schauen wir uns jetzt auf
die nächsten Folien an.
Das eine, was für den Wind relevant ist,
ist die Windrichtung.
Wir müssen ja wissen, welche Windrichtung erwarten wir,
welchen Startplatz gehen wir,
wo ist vielleicht relevanter,
auch für verschiedene Wetterphänomene.
Man kann sich hier vorstellen,
das ist eine Kompassrose mit Norden 0 Grad,
Osten 90 Grad, Süden 180 Grad,
Westen 270 Grad.
Dementsprechend wird der Wind
manchmal auch in Grad angegeben,
von diesen 360 Grad.
Eine Windrichtung wird immer beschrieben,
von wo der Wind kommt.
Wenn der Wind von Süden her kommt,
dann reden wir von Südwind,
Nordwind und Westwind natürlich.
Dementsprechend kommt die Luftmasse von Westen her
und dementsprechend ins Westwind.
Und dementsprechend werden auch
diese Grad angegeben.
Wenn wir einen Wind aus 90 Grad haben,
dann stellt euch diese Kompassrose vor
und der Wind kommt
von 90 Grad von Osten.
Das ist ganz wichtig,
weil in der Meteoriterieprüfung
wird der Wind immer wieder mal
in diesen Grad angegeben.
Und danach müsst ihr wissen,
von was sie reden.
Reden sie von Südwind oder Ostwind usw.
Danach gibt es auch noch eine Windstärke.
Die Windrichtung hatten wir gerade.
Eine Windstärke gibt es
in verschiedenen Masseinheiten.
In der Luftfahrt,
da kommt meistens auch aus der Luftfahrt
ein bisschen diese Sache,
wo der Wind in Knoten angegeben wird.
Da gibt es eine einfache Formel.
Der Wind in Knoten,
also jetzt im oberen Beispiel
die Seeknoten,
mal 2 minus 10%
gibt KmH.
Also Kilometer in der Stunde Wind.
Wo von uns ja ein bisschen
die gängige Masseinheit ist
für Windgeschwindigkeiten,
können wir uns auch mehr darunter vorstellen.
Und in den meisten Wetterstationen
zum Beispiel wird der Wind in KmH angegeben.
2 gibt 40 minus 10%,
das sind dann 4,
gibt die 36 KmH Wind.
Die Umrechnung ist wichtig,
dass ihr die geläufig habt
und präsent habt für die Theorieprüfung.
Dann, was man auch noch so ein bisschen
ins Thema Wind dazu nehmen kann,
ist der Windgradient.
Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt,
dass jetzt hier ein Windsystem kommt,
mit einem Westwind
und der gleitet über die Erdoberfläche,
dementsprechend ist der Wind in der Höhe
meistens stärker,
am Boden unten hat der Wind eine Reibung,
dementsprechend wird er längsamer
und er wird aber auch ein bisschen turbulenter.
Also dementsprechend gibt es
so ein bisschen Grundregeln,
dass in tiefen Schichten,
in badenerischen Schichten
der Wind schwächer ist, aber turbulenter
und in höheren Luftschichten
ist er stärker, aber laminarer.
Logischerweise gibt es dann noch
verschiedene meteorologische Phänomene,
wo ja vielleicht schon einmal
ein bisschen turbulentere Luftmasse
in der Höhe sein kann, oder der ganze auch
und ein Grundsatz ist ja so,
wenn man eine Windströmung kennt,
ist sie am Boden schwächer und turbulenter.
Das zum Windgradient.
Ein Gradient ist übrigens immer
ein Verlauf, jetzt in diesem Sinne,
in der Höhe.
Wir hören dann auch noch ein Temperaturgradient
später im Theoriekurs.
Da geht es immer um einen Verlauf
in der Höhe, wenn man von einem Gradient
redet, oder allgemein von einem Verlauf.
Aber in der Meteorologie geht es
vor allem um die Höhe.
Beim Thema Wind gehört auch noch
ein Thema dazu, das für uns Gletschernflieger
vor allem wichtig ist, und das sind Turbulenzen.
Wir wollen ja möglichst einen ruhigen Flug haben,
respektive, wenn sie einmal Turbulenzen hat,
wollen wir bereit sein und wissen,
warum diese Turbulenzen entstehen
und wie wir diese auch vielleicht
ein bisschen voraussehen können
und in welchen Gebieten wir fliegen
und wenn vielleicht nicht.
Und da gibt es so drei Grundtypen
von Turbulenzen, die man unterscheidet,
die auch in der Theorieprüfung abgefragt werden.
Zuerst einmal sicher die beste Turbulenz,
die sicher angenehm sein kann,
aber vielleicht auch weniger angenehm,
aber die thermische Turbulenz.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die, die wir am meisten
ausgesetzt sind bei der Fliegerei,
weil wir wollen ja thermisch fliegen,
dementsprechend bewegen wir uns immer
in thermische Luftmassen.
Und die, die das schon gespürt haben,
wissen, von wem ich rede.
Und so geht es darum, wenn eine Luftmasse steigt,
die Luftmasse ist ja grundsätzlich relativ ruhig,
liegt sie hier, und dann steigen die thermischen
Turbulenzen auf, die wir dann später
an der Kneue anschauen werden.
Und in dieser steigenden Zone gibt es auch
mehrmals aussen um eine kleine Abwindzone
bei thermischen Aufwind.
Dementsprechend gibt es dort Windschärungen
im vertikalen Bereich.
Und in diesen Windschärungen
spürt man natürlich die Turbulenzen,
dementsprechend die thermischen Turbulenzen.
Dann gibt es die Windschärung in diesem Sinne.
Da geht es darum,
wenn wir zwei verschiedene Windrichtungen haben,
wenn wir unten Westwind haben
und oben haben wir, oder nein,
unten haben wir vielleicht noch ein wenig
Beisen drin, also Ostwind.
Oben haben wir Westwind.
Dann gibt es manchmal eine Mischschicht,
die die zwei Windsysteme aufeinandreffen.
Und dementsprechend gibt es genau
in diesen Höhenmeter, in denen die Winde
aufeinandreffen, eine sogenannte Schärwind.
Und da nehmen wir auch
eine Turbulenz wahr, oder eine leichte
Turbulenz, je nach Windstärke.
Das ist für uns Gleitschirmflüger
jetzt nicht sehr relevant.
Manchmal spüren wir aber Phänomene,
dass es eine Schicht gibt, die ein bisschen rumpelt.
Zum Beispiel für den Realwind.
Darauf kommen wir später noch.
Bei der mechanischen Turbulenz,
das ist noch das dritte Themenfeld,
geht es darum, dass wenn eine
Luftmasse über ein Objekt strömt,
zum Beispiel einen Wald, oder ein Haus,
oder irgendetwas, oder sogar,
vor allem für uns vorrelevant,
bei einer Bergkette zum Beispiel,
wenn wir dort starken Wind haben,
und über dieses Objekt strömt,
ihr kennt das vielleicht alle von diesen
Strömungsvideos von irgendwelchen Autos
und dann gibt es hinter dem Objekt
Verwirbelungen,
die sehr unangenehm sein können.
Je nach Windstärke
können die sehr unangenehm sein,
oder auch gefährlich.
Wenn der Wind aber eher schwach ist,
sind die manchmal auch ganz fein spürbar.
Gerade beim Landeplatz ist das natürlich auch wichtig,
wenn man hinter einem Haus landen würde.
Wenn man starken Wind hat,
ist das natürlich nicht so viel Vorteil.
Hier vielleicht noch zwei Wörter,
die immer wieder aufkommen beim Fliegen,
ist Lauf und Leh.
Das ist ein Thema, das wir uns jetzt
auch kurz anschauen.
Die Lehseite beschreibt immer die
windabgewandte Seite,
und die Laufseite ist die windzugewandte Seite.
Jetzt ist immer die Frage,
von wo aus schauen wir es an?
Schauen wir es von uns aus an?
Schauen wir es von einem Objekt aus an?
Oder, man hört es auch,
man hört sich viel reden am Startplatz,
zum Beispiel auch an Bergkreten.
Da unten haben wir eine Lehseite,
und das ist einfach vom Berg aus gesehen,
die Rückseite des Berges,
wenn die Laufmasse auf diesen trifft.
Oder jetzt in diesem Sinne vielleicht
ein Haus, eine Lehseite des Hauses
und eine Laufseite des Hauses.
In den Landen wollt ihr genau das Gleiche.
Wir bauen laufseitig ab,
vom Landeplatz aus gesehen,
auf der Laufseite,
auf der windzugewandten Seite.
Hier zum Lauf und Leh.
Etwas, das ihr immer wieder hören werdet
in eurer Ausbildung und in der Meteor-Theorie.
Dann kommen wir zum letzten
Wetterphänomen,
wo es um den Wind geht,
was für uns auch ganz, ganz wichtig ist
für Gleitschirmflüger.
Und zwar geht es hier um das Verständnis
des Venturi-Effekts.
Den sogenannten Venturi-Effekt
kennt ihr vielleicht aus der Aerodynamik-Theorie.
Das werdet ihr dort auch noch genauer anschauen.
Im Venturi-Effekt
geht es darum,
wenn immer eine Windströmung
oder eine Luftmasse
dazu gedrängt wird,
um sich zu verengen,
sind im ersten Beispiel
z.B. ein Tal, wenn wir ein breites Tal haben,
das sich auf das Mal verengt
und der Wind dort durchgedrückt wird,
ein Talwind z.B.,
dann gibt es in der Verengung des Tals
eine Windbeschleunigung.
Also dort haben wir deutlich stärkeren Wind
als in der breiten Seite des Tals.
Dementsprechend, wenn man natürlich
von Relevanz fliegt, wenn man viel Wind erwartet,
dass man eher in einem offenen Tal landet
als in einem engen Schlitz,
z.B.
Das ist der Venturi-Effekt.
Wenn man also auf einem Berg
oder auf einem Hügel
mit einer Luftmasse dorthin kommt,
kann man sich vorstellen,
schön parallele Linien dorthin kommen,
der Wind kommt dorthin
und nachher haben wir einen Hügel,
wo die Luftmasse zum Steigen gebracht wird
und dementsprechend führt es zu einer Verengung
auf den Hügel oder auf den Bergkreten oben
und dementsprechend ist die Windgeschwindigkeit
auf dem Berg oben am allerstärksten.
Also wenn ihr mal auf einem Berg steht
und startet oder auf einem Hügel
und es hat sehr starken Wind,
steigt doch, wenn ihr könnt,
je nachdem wie das Gelände zulässt,
ein paar hundert Meter ab
und ihr werdet merken, dass in der unteren Schicht
meistens der Wind sehr viel schwächer ist
als wirklich ganz oben,
voll in der Kompression.
Ist natürlich auch etwas,
was wir vielleicht beim Soaring
in der Flugpraxis anschauen werden
oder vielleicht schon gemacht haben.
Natürlich wichtig ist,
wir wollen ja genau in dem Bereich bleiben,
wo es dann auch den Aufwind gibt,
wo der Wind am Steigen ist.
Zu einer Beschleunigung von einem Wind.
Wegen dem Venturi-Effekt.
Genau.
Jetzt haben wir Windsysteme angeschaut,
Tiefdruckgebiete, Hochdruckgebiete.
Wir haben gelernt, wie man aus den Isobaren
Wind herauslesen kann,
eine Windstärke vielleicht auch herauslesen kann.
Weil je näher die Isobaren zusammen sind,
desto stärker ist der Wind.
Und je weiter auseinander die Isobaren sind,
denkt an eine Topografiekarte,
an eine Landschaftskarte,
je weiter auseinander die Isobaren sind,
desto schwächer ist das Druckgefälle,
desto schwächer ist auch
die Ausgleichsströmung zwischen
diesen Druckgebieten.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass wir
die verschiedenen Themenbereiche
zusammensetzen.
Je tiefer das Verständnis wird,
was mit diesen Luftmassen passiert,
desto mehr kann man zusammensetzen.
Das ist wie ein Puzzlestein,
wo sich das eine ins andere hineinfügt.
Dann wird das Flugwetter
zu einem interessanten Feld
und man freut sich daran,
dass man die Grundlagen versteht
und Basics versteht.
Deshalb ist der Kurs wichtig,
dass man Basics versteht
und nicht einfach etwas auswendig lernt.
Das werden wir weiter anschauen
in den nächsten Folien.
Das einzige Thema, das wir
auf der Isobarenkarte
noch nicht angeschaut haben,
sind die Fronten,
die blauen, roten und violetten Linien
mit den verschiedenen Zeichen drauf.
Diese führen zu speziellen
meteorologischen Bedingungen,
die für uns als Gleitschirmflüger
ganz wichtig sind,
dass man diese versteht
und dass man die Gefahren dieser Fronten versteht.
Aber zum Verstehen der Fronten
nochmals zurück,
wie eine Front überhaupt entsteht.
Wie entsteht eine Front?
Die Luftmassen auf dem Globus
erwärmen sich verschieden.
Wir haben eine kältere Luftmasse
am Polargebiet oben
und eine wärmere, feuchte Luftmasse
am tropischen oder subtropischen Gebiet.
Und wir hatten es vorhin,
eine Luftmasse beschreibt
ein Gebiet, ein Luftvolumen,
das ähnliche Eigenschaften hat.
Da haben wir zwei verschiedene Luftmassen
und zwischendrin gibt es eine
Luftmassengrenze.
Und diese Luftmassengrenze
wird durch eine Front beschrieben.
Wir haben die blauen Dreiecke,
das beschreibt eine Kaltfront
und wir haben die roten Bölen,
also die runden Grafiken
das beschreibt eine Warmfront.
Unten gibt es noch eine Mischform,
eine Okklusion, auf die wir später
noch zugehen, das ist die dritte Form
einer Front, die es gibt.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wir haben die verschiedenen Luftmassen
und jetzt haben wir zum Beispiel
ein Tiefdruckgebiet, das einen Wirbel macht.
Stellt euch vielleicht im Extremfall
einen Hurricane vor.
Das ist wie ein riesiger Wirbel,
das ist ein Mixer, der die Luftmassen
durcheinanderwirbelt und dementsprechend
beginnen sich auch Fronten zu bilden.
Eine Luftmasse zieht vielleicht von Norden
Richtung Süden und eine wärmere Luftmasse
zieht von Süden Richtung Norden
und dementsprechend beginnt sich ein Frontensystem
anzubewegen. Eine Luftmasse wird
bewegt und dementsprechend
austauscht.
Und so entstehen dann Schritt für Schritt
die Fronten.
Da kann man sich jetzt vorstellen,
wir haben zwei Windrichtungen für das Tiefdruckgebiet,
die dortieren beginnen,
wo das ganze Gespann in Rotation
bringt und dementsprechend
diese Fronten bilden.
Was man hier vielleicht auch ganz schön sieht,
ist, dass zuerst
eine Warmfront vorausgeht,
die rote Linie,
und wir haben eine Kaltfront,
die nach hinten geht.
Wir werden uns das nachher noch anschauen.
Eine Kaltfront ist schneller unterwegs
als eine Warmfront.
Eine Kaltfront ist fast doppelt so schnell
wie eine Warmfront.
Und dementsprechend kommt es dazu,
dass die Kaltfront
die Warmfront aufholt
und man sieht es hier
im Zentrum des Tiefdrucks
bilden sich irgendwann die Okklusionen.
Okklusion beschreibt
eine Mischform von diesen zwei Fronten.
Wir werden jetzt gerne noch
genauer im Detail darauf eingehen,
was das bedeutet oder wie das aussieht.
Wir sehen jetzt hier,
wie die Luftmassen dortieren
und wie die verschiedenen Frontensysteme
entstehen durch die zwei Luftmassen.
Jetzt schauen wir uns vielleicht zuerst die Kaltfront an.
Das ist eigentlich fast die wichtigste Front
oder die gefährlichste Front
für Gleitschirmflüger.
Und zwar kommt eine Kaltfront
man kann sich vorstellen,
die zieht von links nach rechts in dieser Grafik.
Die Kaltluftmasse schiebt sich
unten hinein, die ist ja schwerer.
Dementsprechend schiebt sie sich unten hinein
und sie kommt so wie in einer Tropfenform
daher. Da könnt ihr euch merken,
die Form dieser Linie
in der Vertikalen ist eine Tropfenform,
die daherkommt.
Dementsprechend schiebt sich kalte Luft unten hinein.
Die Wärmerluft ist schon leichter
und dementsprechend will sie wegsteigen.
Und dementsprechend kommt es zu
einem grossflächigen
Steigen von dieser warmen,
feuchten Luftmasse.
Und es bilden sich Wolken in diesem Steigprozess,
welche irgendwann ausregnen
und in Extremform sind dann
natürlich Gewitter.
Also bei einer richtig aktiven Kaltfront
kommen immer Gewitter mit her.
Und jetzt sind diese Gewitter
natürlich sehr starker Wind
oder sehr starke Böen.
Das ist natürlich für das Gleitschirmfliegen
extrem gefährlich.
Was bei der Kaltfront natürlich das Problem ist,
im Vorfeld der Kaltfront
haben wir meistens schönes Wetter.
Es ist Sonnenschein,
es ist schönes Wetter,
macht einem an zum Fliegen.
Vielleicht gibt es auch ein wenig Wind.
In der Schweiz ist oft mit Westwind
begleitet oder Südwestwind
oder auch ein bisschen Föhn,
dazu kommen wir später noch.
Aber meistens wird es mit ein bisschen Wind
begleitet, aber oft gibt es auch gute
Wetterkarten.
Es steigt und das ist eigentlich das,
was wir wollen.
Wenn wir jetzt aber auf dieser Wetterkarte
sehen, auf der isobaren Karte,
wo wir ja hoffentlich vor dem Fliegen
immer kurz studieren, dass eine Kaltfront
daherkommt, dann müssen wir wirklich
vorsichtig werden als Gleitschirmflieger,
weil da mit sehr viel Wind zusammenkommt
und auch mit sehr viel steigenden
Luftmassen, wo wir dann wirklich
auch schnell landen müssen.
Bei der Kaltfront ist wirklich angebracht,
dass der Tagesverlauf hineinkommt.
So eine Kaltfront kommt mit 40 bis 70 kmh,
also kann relativ schnell sein,
ganz wichtig. Der Wind kann natürlich
sehr viel stärker werden in Gewitternähe
und sie braucht ungefähr 6 bis 12 Stunden,
bis sie über die Schweiz ausgezogen ist.
Also kann manchmal eine relativ schnelle Sache sein.
Genau.
Also seid vorsichtig
mit diesen Kaltfronten.
Ganz wichtig ist, wenn ihr jetzt im Vorfeld
von einer Kaltfront fliegt, dass ihr immer wieder
den Wetterradar anschaut und vor allem
auch die Augen am Himmel habt.
Da kommen die Gewitter nachher,
das sieht dann ungefähr so aus.
Das Thema Gewitter werden wir uns auch
noch genauer anschauen in diesem Kurs.
Aber für euch auch eine Faustregel,
wenn so Gewitter in einer Linie nachherkommen
auf dem Wetterradar, wie es jetzt hier aussieht,
dann ist es immer extrem gefährlich.
Denn dann ist es wirklich eine sehr aktive Front,
die Gewitter sind sehr stark und
die kommen wirklich wie eine Linie nachher.
Und wenn ihr so eine Gewitterlinie
auf dem Wetterradar seht, dann würde ich
persönlich wirklich sehr schnell landen,
auch wenn die Gewitter noch 100 km weg sind,
und den starken Wind auch vorausschicken.
Und dann kann es Kaltluftausstösse geben
vom Gewitter, die sehr, sehr gefährlich sind
für Gleitschirmflüger,
wo wir nachher im Gewitterbereich
von diesem Theoriekurs
dann noch etwas genauer darauf eingehen werden.
Aber hier zum Wetterradar.
Wichtig beim Wetterradar, noch ein Praxistipp,
schaut nicht nur auf den Radar,
sondern schaut auch auf den Himmel,
denn die Radarbilder sind meistens
eine Viertelstunde alt oder sogar eine halbe Stunde,
je nachdem, schaut, dass sie aktuell sind.
Aber schaut auch auf den Himmel,
auf das Telefon, wenn ihr fliegen geht.
Dann noch ein kleiner Zusatz
zu den Gewittern.
Je näher
im Zentrum eines Tiefdruckgebietes
zum Beispiel, dass man sich
in dieser Front bewegt,
desto aktiver ist eine Kaltfront.
Wenn man nur ganz, ganz am
aussersten Zipfel dieser Front gestreift wird,
wie jetzt hier im Fall von Griechenland,
kann es sein, dass das ganze Wetterphänomen
einfach ein bisschen schwächer ist
und gar nicht so mega schlimm ist,
um vielleicht zu fliegen. Aber seid vorsichtig,
das hat damit viel mit Know-how zu tun.
Aber wenn ihr wirklich voll in der Mitte
einer Kaltfronttreffe getroffen werdet,
dann ist sie wirklich sehr aktiv
und dann ist definitiv nichts zu fliegen.
Aber wenn ihr nur so gestreift werdet,
kann man unter Umständen
gleich noch fliegen
und es führt zu einer leichten
Labilisierung der Luftmasse.
Aber das eher für Fortgeschrittene.
Aber gut zu wissen,
mit dieser Abstufung, dass eine Front
im Zentrum immer stärker ist
als im äussersten Bereich dieser Front.
Dann kommen wir zum
zweiten Frontenphänomen
und das ist die Warmfront.
Die Warmfront ist so,
dass eine wärmere Luftmasse,
wie wir es vorhin gesehen haben,
aufgeleitet wird auf eine kältere Luftmasse.
Bei so einer Luftmasse geht es immer darum,
welche ist kälter oder wärmer.
Das heisst nicht per se, dass eine warm ist.
Man könnte eine Luftmasse haben,
die minus 20 Grad ist
und die andere Luftmasse minus 10 Grad.
Das ist ja auch kalt, aber sie ist kälter.
Also kommt eine wärmere Luftmasse
daher.
Dementsprechend ist die Luftmasse
weniger dicht, etwas leichter
und sie gleitet auf
der kalten Luftmasse auf.
Dementsprechend kommt
eine Warmfront in einer Keilform
daher. Da könnt ihr euch merken,
die Diagonallinie, die Luftmasse
die aufgeleitet wird, bildet
eine diagonale Linie.
Das macht es für uns Gleitschirmflieger
viel weniger gefährlich,
als eine Tropfenform.
Wenn ich jetzt hier unten auf dem Berg stehe
und fliegen möchte, dann sehe ich
sehr viel. Früher, bevor die Front
überhaupt am Boden ankommt,
sehe ich hohe Wolkenschichten.
Der Himmel wird immer milchiger.
Es ist eh nicht so schön
zum Fliegen.
Die Luftmasse kommt immer
weiter runter und dann merkt man
dass es nicht so
gutes Flugwetter ist.
Daher ist die Warmfront viel weniger gefährlich
als die Kalte Front. Aber logischerweise
würde sie auch nicht in einer Warmfront fliegen gehen.
Das ist natürlich auch immer mit Wind verbunden.
Was ihr auch seht, ist,
eine Warmfront kommt sehr viel
längsamer daher.
Sie kommt mit 15-25 kmh
daher. Sie braucht 12-24
manchmal auch mehr Stunden,
bis sie über die Schweiz ausgezogen ist.
Das ist meistens eine etwas längere Geschichte.
Es kann manchmal auch zwei Tage
Flugwetter sein in einer Warmfront.
Und es bringt im Vorfeld,
wie schon besprochen, eine hohe Abschattung,
die die thermische Aktivität
schwächt und
nicht wirklich gutes Flugwetter bringt.
Bei einer Warmfront ist
das einzige Problem, das es vielleicht gibt,
auch für Bergsteiger zum Beispiel,
ist, dass wenn ich hier unten bin,
dann sehe ich nicht durch die Wolkentüren
und sehe, was hinten ist.
Auch bei einer Warmfront kann es hinterher
unter Umständen Gewitter bilden.
Vor allem bei einer Okklusion,
wo wir jetzt gleich dazukommen,
kann es hinterher riesige Gewittertürme geben,
die natürlich sehr gefährlich sind,
weil sie das Wetter mit sich bringen,
starker Wind, starke Niederschläge
und man sieht sie aber gar nicht,
weil wir ja verdeckte Wolkenschichten haben.
Ihr seht hier übrigens noch die Wolkennamen,
die mit einer Warmfront kommen.
Die müsst ihr dann auch lernen.
Die Wolkennamen schauen wir nachher noch an.
Aber vielleicht für euch zum Wissen,
die Warmfront kommt meistens
mit einer Stratusbewölkung.
Also wir haben den Zirostratus, den Altersstratus,
den Nimbostratus, das ist immer mit Stratus verbunden.
Was das Stratus bedeutet
und was das für Wolkennamen sind
und wie die aussehen,
hören wir dann auch in einem anderen Kapitel,
wenn wir die Wolkennamen anschauen.
Aber merkt euch doch,
Zirostratus, Altersstratus, Nimbostratus
wird auch an der Theorieprüfung
sehr wahrscheinlich abgefragt.
Wenn diese Wolkenformen kommen,
dann kann man grundsätzlich schon mal
die Warmfront im Hinterkopf behalten.
Hier noch die Bilder,
wie das herkommt.
Die Wolken sehen so aus,
das sind Schichtwolken.
Das sind die Wolkenteckner,
die immer tiefer runter kommen
im Zeitverlauf der Front.
Und so sehen diese Wolkenformen ungefähr aus.
Dann kommen wir mal
zum Kapitel Okklusion.
Okklusion
müsst ihr eigentlich gar nicht
extrem viel wissen.
An der Theorieprüfung wird es aber trotzdem abgefragt.
Das ist eine Mischform von diesen zwei Fronten.
Und wie besprochen,
ist natürlich für uns
in der Praxis vor allem relevant,
dass bei einer Okklusion oft
der Himmel verdeckt ist
und es sogenannte maskierte Gewitter gibt.
Das sind Gewittertürme, die hinten dran sind,
weil ihr die Warmfront aufholt.
Das ist ja schneller.
Da kann es da hinten Gewitter geben.
Wenn wir aber da vorne sind,
sehen wir vielleicht die Gewittertürme gar nicht.
Und das ist wirklich wichtig für uns,
um zu wissen, dass das passieren kann.
Eine sehr detaillierte Frage,
die nicht extrem viel mit Flugpraxis zu tun hat
oder für die meisten Gleitschimpiloten
nicht von grosser Relevanz ist.
Das sind die Charakter von Okklusionen.
Das wird an der Prüfung auch abgefragt.
Es gibt eine sogenannte Okklusion
mit kaltfronten Charakter
und eine Okklusion
mit warmfronten Charakter.
Dementsprechend, wenn ihr so ein Okklusionsbild
mit den zwei Trennlinien
der Luftmassen seht,
schaut einfach, welche Trennlinie den Boden berührt.
Dementsprechend berührt
in diesem Fall die Linie
der kaltfronten Boden
und im anderen Fall
berührt die Linie
der warmfronten Boden
mit kaltfronten Charakter und warmfronten Charakter.
Hier oben in dieser Grafik seht ihr
einen kaltfronten Charakter.
Das müsst ihr sich für die Theorieprüfung anlernen.
Ist jetzt aber nicht so relevant,
was da die Unterschiede sind
für Normalflüger.
Hier möchte ich nochmal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen, so ein paar Tipps.
Das sind die zwei Karten,
die in der Theorieprüfung am meisten vorkommen.
Vielleicht auf der Linkkarte nochmal zusammengefasst
zum Wiederholen.
Wir haben verschiedene Druckgebiete.
Überlegt euch mal, wo ist der Tiefdruck?
Wo ist der Hochdruck?
Wie rotieren dementsprechend die Luftmassen?
Hochdruck sind Uhrzeigersinn,
Tiefdruck Gegenuhrzeigersinn.
Dann müsst ihr schon mal die Windrichtung.
Stellet euch Kompassrosen vor.
Aus welcher Richtung kommt der Wind?
Dementsprechend Grad.
Wenn die isobaren Linien nahe zusammen sind,
haben wir sehr starke Wind,
wie in diesem Fall von Stockholm.
Wenn sie sehr weit auseinander sind,
haben wir relativ schwachen Wind.
Ich nehme manchmal die Schweiz als Beispiel.
Wenn die isobaren,
wenn wir die Schweiz von der Grösse her nehmen,
gleich nahe zusammen sind,
das ist bei 5 Hektar-Pascal-Schritt noch wichtig,
dann haben wir einen relativ starken Wind,
sobald die isobaren weiter auseinander sind,
wie die Schweiz vielleicht zweimal,
dreimal so breit wie die Schweiz,
dann haben wir eine wirklich schwache Windung.
Dementsprechend haben wir hier im Mittelmeergebiet
ein sehr schwachwindiges Gebiet
und auch im Zentrum des Hochdrucks relativ schwachwindig.
Hier zur Windrichtung
und Windstärke herauslesen.
Dann wird mit diesem Kärtchen hier abgefragt.
Dann haben wir hier die zwei Karten.
Hier seht ihr noch die Fronten.
Dazu müsst ihr vor allem wissen,
welche Bewölkungsformen
mit den Fronten dazukommen.
Hier haben wir sicher
Gewitter in der Kaltfront.
Wir haben vielleicht
ein bisschen Cumulusbewölkung im Vorfeld.
Und hier,
Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich einen Fehler gemacht.
Wir haben hier eine Kaltfront,
die Dreiecke ist ganz wichtig.
Die Formen der Grafiken sind wichtig.
Also wir haben hier Dreiecke,
das ist eine Kaltfront.
Hier ist sicher Gewitter ein Thema.
Und hier haben wir eine Warmfront,
die vorausläuft mit diesen runden Symbolen.
Dementsprechend haben wir
die Statusbewölkungen, wie wir sie gerade besprochen haben.
Und wir haben einen Hochdruck und einen Tiefdruck.
Natürlich ist im Tiefdruck
mit diesen scharferen Linien
geht es immer um Niederschläge.
Hier ist es sicher in Stockholm oben regnet.
Und zum Beispiel in Athen
haben wir Hochdruck-Einflüsse
mit schönem Wetter.
Es hat einen Multiple-Choice-Lerner,
bei dem ihr durchklicken könnt.
Und ihr erinnert euch immer wieder
an die Grundsätze,
die wir gerade besprochen haben,
mit diesen zwei Karten.
Dann seid ihr gut vorbereitet
auf die Prüfung,
welche ISO-Barenkarten und Fronten angeht.
Dann kommen wir zu einem riesigen Thema,
das wichtig ist,
um in der Tiefe lernen zu verstehen,
wenn man wirklich gut Gleitschirm fliegen möchte,
wenn man Strecke fliegen möchte,
und zwar ist das Thermik.
Ich würde vorschlagen,
dass wir kurz eine Pause machen,
damit ihr etwas trinken könnt,
damit ihr den Kopf auslüftet.
Der Kurs geht nämlich noch richtig lang,
wir haben noch richtig viel zu besprechen.
Dann wäre das vielleicht ein Zeitpunkt,
wenn wir das nächste Kapitel anschreiben.